IF THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANKLE.
LAST NIGHT, SOMETHING HAPPENED
ON THIS SHOW SHOULDN’T OF BEEN
THE LEAST BIT CONTROVERSIAL, BUT
IT SENT CERTAIN HARD-CORE FOX
HATING LIBERALS INTO A COMPLETE
FRENZY.
WHAT HAPPENED?
TWO PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT
POLITICAL PARTIES, OFTEN TIMES
WHO FIGHT WITH EACH OTHER, THEY
ACTUALLY DISCUSSED ISSUES WHERE
WE FOUND COMMON GROUND.
COMMON GROUND!
GASP!
OUR GUEST WAS RO KHANNA, A
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRAT.
THE TWO OF US DISAGREE ON ALMOST
EVERYTHING.
A HECK OF A LOT, AT LEAST.
WE SET THAT ASIDE TO FOCUS ON
THINGS WE AGREE ON, MAINLY
MILITARY SPENDING AND OVERSEAS
DEPLOYMENT.
>> LET ME BE CLEAR.
I WAS FOR THE STRIKES IN
AFGHANISTAN.
IF TERRORISTS STRIKE OUR
COUNTRY, WE NEED TO DO THAT.
I SUPPORT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
GETTING THE TROOPS OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
I SUPPORTED PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAYING WE DON’T NEED THEIR TRUE
PRESENCE IN GERMANY.
THERE’S A CONSENSUS THAT WE ARE
SPREAD OUT TOO FAR, AND THIS IS
NOT IN OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Laura: AND TRUMP SPOKE TO
THAT COALITION.
NOW, IN HOUSE, THINK ABOUT THIS.
IT NEITHER THE POPULIST
CONSERVATIVES NOR THE ANTIWAR
DEMOCRATS LIKE CONNOR REPRESENT
MAJORITY.
IT TOGETHER, THEY CAN FORM A
POWERFUL VOTING BLOCK TO MOVE
POLICY AND DEPOSE WHAT MAY BE
COMING DOWN THE PIPE SHOULD
BIDEN ASSUME THE PRESIDENCY.
HIS FOREIGN POLICY TEAM IS
SHAPING UP TO BE FAR MORE
HAWKISH AND INTERVENTIONIST AND
TRUMP’S.
REGARDING BIDEN’S NOMINEE FOR
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE, MICHELLE
FLOURNOY, KHANNA VOICE IS
LEGITIMATE AND IMPORTANT
CONCERNS.
IT’S BECAUSE SHE WAS FOR
ESCALATION IN AFGHANISTAN, FOR
IRAQ, FOR SYRIA.
IF THESE POLICIES HAVE COST US
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
CHINA HASN’T BEEN IN THE WAR
SINCE 1979.
WE’VE BEEN IN 40 WORDS.
IF YOU VIEW CHINA AS A BIGGEST
STRATEGIC COMPETITOR, THAN THESE
POLICIES AREN’T WHAT’S GOING TO
ALLOW AMERICA TO WIN AND
COMPETE.
>> Laura: ABSOLUTELY.
AMERICA NEEDS TO FOCUS ON OUR
OWN COUNTRY’S NEEDS, ESPECIALLY
THE AFTER THE CHALLENGES OF
20/20, MY GOODNESS.
MANY OF US ACROSS THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM BELIEVE THAT OUR
PARTY’S FOREIGN POLICY EXPERTS
HAVE FAILED US FOR DECADES.
HECK, THAT’S ONE OF THE REASONS
TRUMP ONE.
WE ARE HAPPY TO FIND ALLIES IN
OUR BATTLES TO STOP THEM FROM
SELLING US OUT ONCE AGAIN.
>> CONGRESSMAN, KHANNA.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
YOU BACK.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
ISSUES WHERE REPUBLICANS CAN
WORK WITH PROGRESSIVES,
CONSERVATIVES CAN WORK WITH
PROGRESSIVES.
WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU BACK
IF THIS DEVELOPS.
>> I APPRECIATE THAT, I WOULD
LOVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
>> Laura: AT THAT MOMENT WAS
ENOUGH TO BLOW THE FACE MASKS
OFF THE CRAZIES.
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY, SOCIAL MEDIA
LIT UP.
AARON REPORTER AT VOC TWEETED,
I’M NOT SURE WHY ANY DEMOCRAT
WOULD VALIDATE LAURA INGRAHAM’S
SHOW BY GOING ON IT FOR A
FRIENDLY INTERVIEW BUT THAT’S
WHAT RO KHANNA ADJUSTED.
KHANNA RESPONDED, PLEASE WATCH
THE INTERVIEW.
IT’S ABOUT CUTTING THE DEFENSE
BUDGET AND STOPPING WARS.
IF SOMEONE ON FOX IS WILLING TO
TALK ABOUT CUTTING THE DEFENSE
BUDGET, WHY NOT ENGAGE?
HE WENT ON TO NOTE THAT GREAT
PEOPLE LIKE LINCOLN AND
DR. KING WERE ABLE TO BUILD
IMPORTANT COALITIONS IN THE PAST
AND SAYS HE BELIEVES IN THE
POSSIBILITY OF OVERLAPPING
CONSENSUS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS, THE
ESTABLISHMENT BOTH PARTIES OVER
30 YEARS HAVE GOTTEN SOME BIG
ISSUES WRONG.
IRAQ, SYRIA AND CHINA, JUST TO
NAME A FEW.
THE ISSUE OF ENDLESS WARS,
LIBERALS AGREE WITH TRUMP’S
POSITION.
EVEN IF THEY DON’T WANT TO GIVE
TRUMP CREDIT.
>> NO GREAT NATION FIGHTS
ENDLESS WARS.
IT’S TIME TO BRING OUR COMBAT
TROOPS HOME.
>> DON’T BE FOOLED BY TRUMP’S
ARGUMENT THAT HE’S PULLING
TROOPS OUT OF THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> THEY ARE WORRIED THAT WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE INVOLVED IN
ENDLESS WARS.
>> I SIGNED A PLEDGE TO ENTITY
FOREVER WARS.
>> Laura: LIBERALS HAVE TO
ADMIT THAT TRUMPS ANTIWAR RECORD
OVER FOUR YEARS SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF.
IT’S UP TO THE GRASSROOTS AND
BOTH PARTIES TO PUSH THEIR
LEADERS INTO A MORE POSITIVE
DIRECTION FOR THE REGULAR
WORKING PEOPLE.
REPUBLICANS DID THAT IN BOTH
ELECTIONS, OVERWHELMINGLY
SUPPORTING TRUMPS AMERICA FIRST
AGENDA, AND TO GROWING HIS
POPULARITY AMONG THE VOTERS.
DEMOCRATS SHOW BIDEN, WHO ON KEY
FOREIGN POLICY ISSUES ACTUALLY
AGREES WITH THE OLDER G.O.P.
ESTABLISHMENT.
THIS IS WHERE THE LEFT RIGHT
COALITION MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
HERE’S A QUICK OVERVIEW A BOY OR
WE CAN WORK TOGETHER.
IF NUMBER ONE, WE CAN PRESERVE
TRUMPS TARIFFS ON STEEL AND
ALUMINUM, WHICH WOULD SAVE JOBS
IN THOSE KEY INDUSTRIES.
A NUMBER TWO, WE CAN SUPPORT THE
ONGOING ANTITRUST INVESTIGATION
AND PUSH FOR OVER RESTRAINTS TO
LIMIT BIG TECH.
WE CAN OPPOSE THE TRANSPACIFIC
OWNERSHIP OR OTHER DEALS NOT
SUPPORTED BY WORKERS.
WE CAN STICK TO ALL AMERICO
RULES FOR SPENDING.
IF THIS REQUIRES AN IMPORTANT
CHANGE IN LAWS AS IT’S CURRENTLY
WRITTEN.
NUMBER FIVE, WE CAN SUPPORT A
STRONG INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
THAT WILL CREATE JOBS FOR
AMERICANS.
YES, AMERICANS.
AS KHANNA AND I DISCUSSED LAST
NIGHT, WE CAN PUSH TO BRING HOME
ALL TROOPS IN THE MIDDLE EAST
AND REDUCE OUR MILITARY
COMMITMENTS THAT ARE NOT
DIRECTLY AIMED AT CHIME IN.
THIS WILL MEAN INSISTING THAT
EUROPE DO MORE TO DEFEND ITSELF.
TRUMP IS DONE THE RIGHT THING ON
EVERY ONE OF THESE ISSUES.
IF PROGRESSIVES REALLY CARE
ABOUT WORKING PEOPLE, IT WOULD
BE WISE TO WORK WITH US TO IT
GET ME SHARED GOALS.
AS FOR THE MEDIA, EVERYONE ABOUT
THIS INTERVIEW LAST NIGHT.
I REMEMBER WHEN THEY LOVE THE
IDEA OF EVERYONE GETTING ALONG.
>> HE BELIEVED IN THE GREEN
LIGHT, HIS GREEN LIGHT WAS
BIPARTISANSHIP.
>> IT CALLS, OF COURSE.
>> DOES THAT STILL EXIST ON
ISSUES THAT YOU TALK TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE AND
SAID, LET’S WORK TOGETHER ON
THIS?
>> Laura: THEY ONLY LIKE
BIPARTISANSHIP WHEN IT ADVANCES
BECAUSE THE ELITES CARE ABOUT.
IT’S SO OBVIOUS AND SO CYNICAL.
SMART PEOPLE SEE THROUGH THROUGH
SPIRIT OF PROGRESSIVES WITH
INTEGRITY RESPONDED FORCEFULLY
TO THE HATERS WHO ATTACK 36
APPEARING ON THE ANKLE.
THEY SAID RO KHANNA SHOULD GO ON
THE MOST POPULAR NEWS NETWORK.
WHAT IS FOX’S THEORY OF CHANGE?
TRANSMITTING THE SAME
INFORMATION TO THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO AGREE WITH THEM OVER AND
OVER?
BINGO.
IT’S CALLED POLITICS.
THE POINT OF POLITICS IS MAKING
PEOPLE’S LIVES BETTER.
A MEAN SOMETIMES WORKING WITH
PEOPLE YOU DON’T NECESSARILY
LIKE.
AS THE SQUAD, AOC PLUS THREE,
ARE THEY CAPABLE OF SOLVING
THEIR TRIP FOR TRUMP SUPPORTER’S
IN ORDER TO IMPROVE LIGHT FOR
THEIR CONSTITUENTS?